hello everyone welcome to today's live
broadcast and keno presentation evolving
paradigms of pharmaco MPE molecular
pathological
epidemiology and immuno MPE for
precision medicine presented by dr.
Tsuji Oh Gino a professor at dana-farber
Cancer Institute
Brigham and Women's Hospital Harvard
Medical School and Harvard th Chan
School of Public Health
he's also the founding chief of program
in molecular pathological epidemiology
at Brigham and Women's Hospital and an
associate member of Broad Institute of
MIT and Harvard I am dr. Susie Valdez of
laborat and I'll be your moderator for
today's event we're delighted to bring
you this educational web seminar
presented by lab roots lab roots is a
leading scientific social networking
website and producer of educational
virtual events and webinars before we
begin I want to remind everyone that
this event is interactive we encourage
you to participate by submitting as many
questions as you want at any time you
want during the presentation just click
on the ask a question box located on the
far left of your screen and type those
questions into the drop down box that
appear on the screen dr. Oh Gino will be
responding to all of your questions via
email if you have any trouble hearing or
seeing the presentation please click on
the help desk button located on the
promotional board at the bottom center
of your screen or use that ask a
question box and let us know you're
having a problem this presentation is
educational and that's offers continuing
education credits click on the
continuing education credit tab located
at the top right corner of your
presentation window and follow the
process for obtaining those credits
without further ado please join me in
welcoming our keynote presenter dr.
Tsuji Oh Gino I will now turn the
presentation over to him welcome sir
hello thank you very much for watching
and listening to my lecture entitled
evolving power the farmer called MPE
molecular pathological epidemiology and
the immuno MP for precision medicine
Sugeno chief of programming MP at the
Brigham Women's Hospital and professor
of pathology and epidemiology of Brigham
Women's Hospital dana-farber Cancer
Institute Harvard Medical School and
Harvard th Chan School of Public Health
and also associate member who brought
the Institute of MIT and Harvard which
wasn't listed here so but so so today's
talk I have three abbreviations I often
use I illustrate here weren't CRC
standing for colorectal cancer and MP
for a molecular pathological
epidemiology and MSI for microsatellite
instability and by the way this MSI is
an indicator of hypermutated stages of
many human type with many new neo
antigens and fda approved last year uses
of immune checkpoint inhibitor panel is
map for MSI high solid tumors across
body side so this is very important
biomarker now
so now I just talked about
briefly introduce molecular pathological
epidemiology MPE as names stands for
this is a merger of molecular pathology
and
epidemiology and this is not just a
merger of names the merge of integration
of a method which is a critical in this
field and
I think this is it's it is clear that
this MP is you know also equal to big
data path of biological population
science and
it can help with drug development that I
like to illustrate in this lecture and
then I would like to also announce that
we have a fourth now already fourth
international molecular pathological
epidemiology meeting in Boston USA in
from March 31st to June first and this
is a free meeting open for international
community so please register and on also
submit the abstract to if you're
interested and then this MP that org MP
meeting that always a meeting site you
can actually go
so so why probably you've never heard of
Pharma Co MP as well as the immuno MP so
I would like to illustrate why this
approach these approaches are useful
and
here are just illustrate complex
biological systems
so here the tumour I yesterday the tumor
cells and immune cells but obviously
there are other stromal cell types
not-not-not the demonstrated here for
the sake of simplicity but nonetheless
tumor cells and immune cells have a very
very complex
interactions with each other and also
the tumor cell immune cell interact each
other as well and they are but we
frequently
examine these interactions and possibly
with maybe a drugs or genetic variation
now also microbiota but also other
exposures such as diet nutrients obesity
for example
environmental exposures such as smoking
and other air pollution for example
those have been known to influence
micro environment but those are not
studied in current immunology research
which I have I I was interested in going
in actually several years ago
so that I these concept first actually
conceptualized in 2011 and
so the because it is a big challenge to
recapitulate these complex interactions
in experimental models and so let's get
the data from human population human
tissue human tumors that's our goal and
also new drugs always need to be tested
in humans so
even even drug working model systems
perfectly he may not work in real human
tissue
human body so we have to really tested
using a human specimens human tissue
and another another interesting thing we
have known for many years now is the
exposures I just put diet obesity and
environment genetic variation microbiota
and drug with all those can easily
influence the tumor micro environment
including immune cell so
so traditional or type of molecular
pathological epidemiology we pretty much
focus on tumor cell molecular pathology
but now we really need to consider
immune cells and tumor cells together to
have to gain more insights into
pathogenesis and the role of exposure
variables
so one study we conducted in
collaboration with dr. gulab at the
Broad Institute years ago is here so
exposure and stroma can change tumor
phenotype so basically
melanoma with the Bureau of mutation
our sensitivity roughly inhibitor but if
we continue use RAF inhibitor there are
enormous error develop resistance and
how they develop
resistance is actually the stromal cell
secret hgf a bad side growth factor and
then the that this growth factor confers
resistance
of melanoma cell against RAF inhibitor
so actually tumor cell and stromal cell
works together and then exposure such as
a drug can actually modify phenotype
tumor stromal interaction so this is a
very important concept
so so this question still
here but anyway I think it is important
to consider exposures and tumour cells
and immune cells all together and then
drugs so that's why pharmaco mp1 and
also immuno MP important approach
here is some example i put some
exposures which have been known to
influence cancer risk especially I mean
analyzing colorectal cancer but
exposures inference and both cancer
risks and immunity so one example is
aspirin aspirin
has been known to reduce cancer risk but
also moderate inflammation and immune
immunity and so as a genetic variation
here is omega-3 fatty acids rich in fish
oil and vitamin D which produced by some
food and also a sun exposure and
physical activity can you know this has
been known to boost the immune system
and
smoking
is considered to suppress immune
response
etc and there are every all these
exposures we looked it seems they
influenced cancer risk differentially by
immune response status then I will show
you data some of them however
immuno MP studies are still very rare
and we need to do more immuno MP studies
so here I think just a very very simple
picture it's really
oversimplification oversimplification of
a tumor and the immune response
relationship but nonetheless I just go
over here but the tumor cell have a
mutation in some genes and which give
rise to
mutated peptide some of them will become
new antigens to be presented to immune
system and the immune response happened
to against tumor cell and then our tumor
cells develop counter suppressive
mechanisms such as a progression of
immune checkpoint to suppress immune
response
so for example a well-known example is
the CD 274 on a PDA one expression that
can suppress the immune response and
tumor cells survive
and we have shown that this within
colorectal cancer the CD 2004 expression
PDL wanks pressure is inversely
associated with the contents of Fox p3 T
reg regulatory t-cell in tumor tissue so
this is really a mutually exclusive
mechanism of
immunosuppression and
then there are other methods to
interrogate
immunity new response status in tumor
but anyway in epidemiologic studies most
commonly used immune variable is perhaps
a German variation so far for example et
al awzai and also the blood markers are
commonly used such as CRP and il-6 and
the immune cells in the tumor
microenvironment that I
this is the main topic of today's
lecture and here I related
H&E staining of the current cancer
tissue with abundant immune cell in the
stroma as well as human infiltrating
lymphocytes on top of tumor cell so
those are strong prognostic factor and
we have shown I mean actually this is
not a published data we have published a
small subset of our cohort many years
ago but this is based on more than 1400
cases of colon rectal cancer we clearly
see nice prognostic value of immune
response which is better than any other
molecular marker actually these are the
very low immune responders and the high
immune responses virtually no metallic
within the three plus
high-level immune responder
so I just like to now illustrate
molecular pathology epidemiology
database and then we show I I will show
actual pharmaco MP and the immuno MP
data
so I I have been working on these two
cohort studies
obviously I haven't started the working
at the Harvard from night in
1976 butter and this studied more than
40 years ago and I joined
Harvard in 2001 to get involved in this
cohort study this common study is
you know gather a hundred twenty
thousand women and forward more than
forty years or more and we have a lot of
data of exposures and diseases and then
up so the 1986 health professional for
up study started with a fifty thousand
men and then the good value of these
cohort studies
the fact that the
participants were followed every two
years by questionnaire how they eat how
they exercise how they exposed to
smoking alcohol and then we collect the
biospecimens there
so basically these cohort studies you
know more than hundred thousand men and
women we collect a dietary lifestyle
environment and then we get the
biospecimens like a blood to get the
genetic data as well as plasma
biomarkers and now even metabolomics
data
so during follow-up over 40 or 30 years
obviously some of them develop cancer
and then my interest is analyzing
colorectal cancer and polyps in these
cohort studies and actually I receive
NCI are thirty-five outstanding
investigator award which is a seven-year
major grant and you know to carry this
job and this you know this analysis
actually a theme one in this hour thirty
five award so in this so I might ask is
analyzing molecular pathology of the
tumor including whole exome sequencing
now and also we are analyzing tissue
microbiota as well as the numerous
spawns in a way we assess mortality over
patients or recurrence
over polyps and
then we get a very unique finding in the
pathogenesis of colorectal cancer
so here is the data from new antigen
node analysis from whole exome
sequencing of a thousand tumors
so the new antigen is it is a new group
also called the Neo peptides so we
calculate the you know mutated the
peptide which can bind to high affinity
to HLA molecule so we have a germline
whole exome data too so we can actually
estimate how many men how many neo
peptides actually bind to HLA molecule
to be presented then n the predictor it
may predict the response to
immunotherapy so it can be a biomarker
in immunotherapy field so we clearly
show that hi new antigen load they have
a better outcome compared to linear
design load
this is published in cell report paper
also in the cell report paper we
published that the association between
number of neo antigens on the y-axis in
a log scale and then a lymphocytic
reaction which calculated based on
histopathologic variation which highly
correlated
both sudra so the tumor has more new
antigens and they have more immune
immune reaction realistic reaction
however there are overlaps and then some
of the
hydrophilic reaction tema they have
relatively lower new antigens and some
of the
low realistic reaction chemical have a
high yawns enter and we like to know
why right now we're analyzing
also in the same report paper we we
analyzed the number of genes of
antigen presenting machinery
antigen so antigen processing machinery
and we found a number of interesting
finding so so these numbers indicate
percent mutated in immuno tumors on the
left and then immune hakima on the right
so you can see the higher percent of
mutations observed for immune high tumor
from a number of
machinery protein like HLA worm
chunks and
b2m and so forth other antigen
presenting machinery mutations are more
common in in enriched tumor and we
consider this can be
you know adaptive mechanism of tumor
you know they don't they tend not to
present in your antigen so that they can
avoid immune attack
so now I would like to illustrate we are
molecular pathological epidemiology
analysis so here is a basic scheme so we
have one hundred seventy thousand
participants persons with normal color
when they started forward and then some
of them develop colorectal cancer with a
very variable product time but we have
about a thousand six hundred colorectal
cancer cases with the tissue available
we can look into immune response status
so we can subtype based on immune
response status and then which are
actually linked specific exposure such
as filling or omega-3 fatty acid to a
specific immune subtype that's major
strengths of this analysis and also we
can actually focus on the colorectal
cancer cases and then we have immune
subtype data and that we like to know
what kind of exposure inference which
subtype which immune subtype of a cancer
and this information can be used for
adjuvant treatment for example a
speeding treatment may be useful for one
subtype or the other we can have a
predictive biomarker of immune status
so for example our
already this is all our six years ago in
the New England Journal Medicine we
published paper that aspirin
has been known to reduce cancer
mortality but particularly a pik3ca
mutated some type of tumor but not
pik3ca wartime tumor
and here is a raw data so pictures the
mutant subgroup we can see substantial
difference between Aspen user and non
user so far this is a probability of
death so usually survival analysis
Cobras are flipped but this a speeding
user have a lower mortality
compared to non user however the pixel
is a wild-type group
this there was no difference whatsoever
between non user and aspirin user so
this is a quite interesting and we
actually conducted in vitro study
comparing a pik3ca
wild-type cell lines and then pics with
the mutant cell lines they have a
variable
genotype but we try to get as many as
possible and then interestingly pixel is
a mutant subtype seem to be more
sensitive to aspirin compared to Pixies
a wild type cell lines so this actually
back up our
observational MP study
published in encode target and actually
similar data published in this cancer
prevention research
from a gel coil group in Texas
and also there is a similar data in
breast cancer cell line studies as well
and then we also we so the pixie is
great to predict responders however we
also interested in immune immune marker
interaction with aspirin so one marker
we are interested is this 3274 PDL
expression and we hypothesize that if
this mute checkpoint activated it could
be
lower sensitivity to aster so when we
look at our data
it's true that in the PPD 2004 PDA high
subtype which is supposed to be immune
checkpoint activated the aspirin
is not associated with survival however
this CD 2 7 for PDA one low subtype
regular use of aspirin
it is associated with much better
outcome compared to non user
so is this difference is very
significant so and then this also
differential association seem to be
independent of pick CCL subtype actually
our pixel is a wild-type
you can use this CD to 7/4 expression to
further separate responders in pixels
the mutants are actually they respond so
well so we don't have enough
mortality data to be promised but at
least the Pixies here world type this CD
274 can be another
predictive marker to separate responders
and non-responders
so our data suggests that if this CD
2004 expression is high then they know
really as the the tumor is resistant to
aspirin and but this checkpoint is not
activated then they respond to aspirin
which is quite interesting and then our
question is now how
how about this checkpoint inhibitor
with a combined with us being and then
that's the steerer open question and I
think
we hope to see if this combination
therapy works
so now we going into cancer incidence
side of analysis so we interested in
preventing cancer
because if we prevent cancer we don't
need to worry about treatment or side
effect or surgery so
our our our data is very very precious
because we we have been following
hundred seventy thousand individuals and
we have
outcome data with the immune response
and we have all the exposure data
collected before cancer diagnosis so
these exposure data are free from bias
from cancer diagnosis
so one good example is we published more
than 10 years ago in New England general
medicine so we look at incidence of
cancer
classified by this enzyme PD just to
status
another name is a cyclooxygenase to a
cocktail which it's a major target of
aspirin so we actually nicely show that
aspirin is associated with lower risk
for this PD just to hide subtype but not
the PD just to low subtype this makes
total sense
however
however we publish this as a seller
after more than ten years
still no four of paper whatsoever
because this data as I measure is hard
to come up with we have hundred seventy
thousand people forward
thirty or forty years I mean this time
2007 period at the 20 or 30 years of
follow-up still and then we collect the
tissue we have PD just to expression
data so this is a very very precious
data set but nonetheless
we don't have any for updater so we hope
that you know I think the international
research community will come up with big
population-based data set to validate
finding such as this
so now I talk about the drugs and
tumorous interactions but now we just
switch gear to microbiota because this
is a very hot topic too so we have been
interested in microbiota for more than
five years now in particular species
we're interested in is fuse of bacteria
nuclear atom in human tissue this
habit shown to be a likely you see
colorectal cancer pathogen and then lots
of many studies now show that this
future bacterium nuclear atom positive
tumor he has a lower immune response and
the
experimental data suggests
immunosuppressive property of a few the
bacterium nuclear atom and also
associated these positive cases are also
associated with the higher stage and in
shorter survival
so
so obviously our interest is that how
gut microbiota
affects the cancer risk and the outcome
and then probably gut microbiota is
influenced by diet
because diet goes to color I mean and
then the the youth the bacteria can use
the nutrients and so forth so first of
hypothesis we made is the vegetables and
whole grains and beans of fiber-rich
diet which
show up as a prudent diet pattern we
call these are the dietary patterns
by a factor analysis of a bunch of food
items and this this prudent diet can be
associated with I think the growth of a
good bacteria and suppression of bad
bacteria in God
in the suppression of colorectal cancer
in particular this feels a bacterial
nuclear atom positive type so that's our
hypothesis to test
say this is the real deal that we we
already published last young German
oncology so here is a fuse of bacterium
nuclear term positive cancer risk
according to food and diet score so
basically law indicates lower prudent I
score low dietary fiber basically in the
high prudent I score is reaching based
of all great whole grains and beans and
rich in fiber so basically this prudent
diet is associated with the lower risk
for future bacterium new creative
positive cancer a
significant reduction of risk however
feel the bacterium negative cancer
there's no risk reduction whatsoever and
then the difference was also statistical
significant too
so we based on this data we speculate
these prudent diet rich in fiber
is associated with lower risk and
suppressing the development of fuser
bacterium new create and positive cancer
and not not influencing fuser bacterium
new creative negative cancer type so
these are classification based on tissue
microbiota can be very very informative
in a molecular pathological epidemiology
so modifying microbiota can be crc
prevention strategies so for example
this is a good example is prudent diet
reaching vegetables whole grains beans
and dietary fiber I would recommend this
so-called healthy diet and also maybe
probiotics I not sure about antibiotics
but it is yogurt and for healthy
bacteria may be helpful although data
are lacking and we analyzing our own
data on the intake of yogurt now and
actually antibiotic regarding
antibiotics long-term antibiotics use
for respiratory infection urinary tract
infection acne rosacea dental reason it
can increase risk for colorectal adenoma
we published in God so I think on a
long-term antibiotic use may be disturb
the gut microbiome microbiota and it can
increase risk for colorectal adenoma and
cancer so we like to get into how they
increase risk in a mechanistic way
we have done so now I you know continue
on to immuno MPT my next target is this
marine omega-3 polyunsaturated fatty
acids which is rich in fish oil
basically
so the fish oil or this marine omega-3
tu FA
has been associated with the correct
lower curve rectal cancer risk but
epidemiologic data are conflicting not
really conclusive and then some
experimental data suggest marine omega-3
fatty acid can inhibit regulatory
t-cells and it can stimulate affects the
t-cell so what we are interested in is
is Fox p3 tear a regulatory t-cell and
the functionally it's very interesting
group of t-cell azam and also study
having shown Fox pc+ T reg very
heterogeneous and different functions
not nonetheless so this is a kind of a
simplified hypothesis but omega-3 fatty
acid intake can suppress T reg and then
if T legs suppressed then immune
response can be stimulated in the
eliminate
emerging tumor so that's our very simple
final processes
so
so this is a hypothesis in in a in a
cohort
scheme and we have exposure as a
omega-3 fatty acid as an exposure and my
hypothesis is that this
omega-3 fatty acid suppress the
development of corrector chance' which
have more abundant Fox p3 T reg but not
the other type
so we published this in also JAMA
oncology 2016 and so we've separate Fox
p3
positive cell hi type so these have a
rich T reg cells in tumor tissue and
these are not and then this x-axis is a
marine omega-3 fatty acid intake so low
is virtually no fish and the high is
lots of fish and other sources
supplemental so actually you can really
see that cancer risk for this Fox p3
high cell high-type
decreased by intake of
omega-3 fatty acids
substantially
however Fox PCL Fox p3 positive sell low
type and they are not the cancer risk
are not influenced by omega-3 fatty acid
so it's it's quite interesting our data
our data from cohort studies actually
back up this kind of a simple simple
hypothesis we made submarine omega-3
fatty acids may suppress T reg function
regulatory t-cell function and then that
can stimulate immune response to
eliminate if emerging tumor cells
so I
think that we have enough we have shown
example of immuno MP in the microbial MP
but I mean so this is a kind of my own
out and investigate award grant sibling
a grand
theme to is we I plan to expand the
population science you know frontiers so
obviously molecular pathological
epidemiology I I proposed back in 2010
which is really growing with
international meeting series now we are
going into
other field to
collaborate and then getting more
insights so the one such example is I
show this immuno MPE and also a
microbial MPI show example of a fuse of
bacterium new creatin and also we have
been already analyzing a stirring more
than 10 years but
so this area can be named as a farmer
called MPE it's a pharmacology
integrated with molecular pathology and
epidemiology so to analyze
drugs is common drugs used in
populations to examine the really affect
on the other diseases so people taking
aspirin probably for prevention of
cardiovascular disease or pain it can be
predicted preventive against the cancer
or other diseases - what may be causing
some other disease so we have to really
analyze big data set population-based
data on a sphere and then disease
phenotype so that's what we are aiming
and by by naming this field as a farmer
call em PE
and I also show example of nutritional
MP and I mean nutritional epidemiology
has been around for decades but now we
are interested in looking into molecular
pathology as well as
microbiota and the immunology so
actually I put all for a separate way
but really we can actually consider
these as whole thing as a new frontiers
of MPE
so those are more like a path of
biological new frontiers
into
you know many different directions but
also we are interested in
developing statistical methods because
this molecular pathology idea of a human
classification bringing lots of
challenges in epidemiology so we
actively develop in a statistical method
we which I haven't discussed in this
talk but if you are interested in we
published the represented paper in
statistics min Medicine
2016
and then another area is a causal
inference MPE so the causal inference is
the one subfield of
epidemiology which developing
mathematical
algorithm to tease out
observational data and actually simulate
observational data into trial data so
that you know the the
Association can be free of confounding
so this a mathematical algorithm can be
integrated into
MPE to help elucidate causality much of
it away so we have this recently we
published a new European Journal of
Epidemiology
using an inverse probability weighting
so that's one direction also we have
published Network science and MP dataset
integration so forth so really we are
pushing
molecular pathological epidemiology into
other setting and other exposures and
also the method development so that's
the main focus of my current my work
so to summarize my talk
molecular pathological epidemiology MPE
can provide new insights which are no no
other approach can an MP's making new
frontiers such as pharmaco MPE and
imminently nutritional p microbial MP
and so forth and complex drug
environmental interactions necessitate
pharmaco MP paradigm for a discovery and
validation of new drug use
and
then i would say this immuno MP model I
mean immunity studies as I said there is
no many other group was still
published paper and I know many other
groups actually working on them but
still kind of an open field and there
are lots of opportunities for immunity
studies and one reasons exposures can
easily influence tumor micro-environment
the example I showed it a spinning
omega-3 fatty acids microbiota and I
didn't show but I we have a data engine
on genetic variation as well as smoking
as well they really easily influenced
tumor cell much easier than tumor genome
actually so let's look at immune cells
so I like to acknowledge
so many people helped me or involved in
the big cohort studies and also there
are many collaborators and I cannot list
everyone nonetheless I would like to
particularly thank
dr. Charlie Fuchs with a head of a Yale
Cancer Center and
undie Chan at the Mass General Hospital
and also a the Joe Valachi at the
Harvard th Chan School for Girls and
then water we had Lori I'm with cheese
RPI's / health professionals for up
study Amir Stamper Frank Brothers a
gross thing is a pie of Nurses Health
Study and also like to thank Jonathan
Nowak raccoony Shara as a colleague in
the pathology at the Brigham Women's
Hospital and
also I'd like to thank Nurses Health
Study and health professional for up
study
participants across the country in
various hospitals and pathology
departments for providing us precious
tissue materials so these are the
breakdown of where the teach come from
and accept North Dakota and Alaska we
got the Tisch from all other states and
then we like to thank funding and also
laboratory members and
thank you very much for your attention